how's it going before this video begins
I got an exciting announcement me and
Marcia together for the first time
launched a project together our own
brand called Sookie I'm wearing one
right now
at Sookie's Japanese for moon of course
we're obsessed with Japan it's a unisex
clothing brand so it doesn't matter if
you're a boy or girl or a creature of
the night you can still wear it Sookie
we also have some home product as well
it's all ethically made and it's all
designed by us so yeah one of the items
I really wanted to have was his mock
neck that you got this Sookie logo on it
I love this thing we also launched an
oversized hoodie super comfortable super
cool fit on it very unique we also got
our pink t-shirt with the Sookie logo
along with a cap I love this cap so much
finally one that actually fits my damn
head
we even have if you're feeling very
fashion-forward and cool like myself a
beret that's right
bet you didn't expect that we also have
very cool Sookie socks along with a
Sookie planner candle that we selected
with the scent and yeah check it out the
stock is limited so once it's out its
out you're gonna it's now or never
basically so check it out I'm really
proud of it I'm really proud of me -
they're finally doing a product together
it was a really fun thing to do and
hopefully you'll like it as well I think
we can all agree that YouTube is pretty
[ __ ] wonderful YouTube is the greatest
of course what else did you think I was
going to say today I'm going to review
YouTube can't even say it
today we're going to review some of the
finest videos and some of the finest
comments left on the website you know me
I care about the little man I care about
giving shoutouts to smaller channels
giving them some hope that day one day
could become the Knicks feed eBay what
am I talking about moving on all right
here we have a perfect example
stop disliking my videos
with Joey viola he can hack you
hey the other one sorry I'm not your mom
oh no you if you're the one they just
might do more videos I swear I'm going
to [ __ ] you up
hello the angle it's great if you're the
one that dislikes so many tears I swear
I'm gonna miss you it's mrs. YouTube
truly is a fine place for scholars and
gentlemen get out of here
subscribe disliked great what else fine
videos can you find on this wonderful
website you can really find anything how
to pick up a blue chair after ground mmm
seems interesting nice - ouch hey guys
thanks for coming a Bluetooth page
alright today I'm gonna do a new
tutorial how to pick up chairs fall it
falls down you need is just to lift the
chair does it get up just leave it
thinking that's like fine chair we have
there Allen but have you seen my chair
perhaps you know this chair basically
can't even fall down YouTube is truly an
amazing website but what really thrives
is the community I'm talking of course
about the comments on YouTube they're
the best some of the finest some of the
most intellectuals on this website stays
in the youtube comments that's how you
can find them listening to this from
Australia that's so sick thanks for the
support I didn't say I liked it or he
was good
OOP
like wow it's so great when creators
interact with their fans on YouTube
truly inspiring Steve here's someone
decided to upload Michael Sarah's face
isn't it great how people are creative
on this website I'm a kid I'm nine I'm
nine and a half shut [ __ ] up I was a
little harsh but sometimes you got to
put fans to place they always try and
one-up you with their BS you need to
shut up LM oh nice hacks how many
chromosomes do you have more than you
for sure oh damn you don't mess with
with Z PvP he's got so many chromosomes
he'll take you back to the Stone Age
damn like I stuck that guy's hardcore
I'm truly proud to be thriving on this
wonderful platform it feels great it
feels just what I wanted to spend my
life on guys I regret to inform you that
PewDiePie is suffering from cancer but
he doesn't want his subscribe it would
be too sad for them what no liar I am
serious I am his doctor and I diagnosed
him with it sorry why does everything
bad ever happen to me DOM is of course
correct I he is my doctor I'm surprised
he leaked is clearly confidential
information no one was supposed to know
what was going on with my boss when he
fiddled with them don't worry Brett I'll
be fine with or without my nuts I'll be
keep making videos because I just love
making YouTube video so much that even
if I get a life-threatening disease I am
NOT going to drop it I am going to keep
on grinding so hopefully it will kill me
sooner anyone know the song
yes thanks no problem
isn't it wonderful where the YouTube
community comes together and work
together as a team
oh it's truly inspiring oh I've only my
community would still have for my
community is so toxic me me kicking a
wall for 12 minutes and 29 seconds until
my dad tells me to stop finally someone
that could be the next beauty pay let's
watch what is this how to basics son
does he dad actually Cutler
oh wow we have found the best video on
YouTube guys we have officially peaked
congratulations to Lake man you win this
award can't wait to see what else leg
man is going to make in the future watch
the whole thing loved it
watch the whole long ditch close enough
come on I just want to watch black ops 3
gameplay make your screen smaller please
stupid ladies get out can this stupid
lady gets out of the scene I need to see
those flowers wow are those roses I said
it super king size bed
and who said why people have no culture
isn't it wonderful finally why people
have found their culture thanks to
YouTube we have something to be proud of
diary 30 Superman is coming to school
diary 31 humiliation let's watch good
morning
no I can't watch this the thing about
YouTube is there's an endless ocean of
content but only the best there only the
finest rises to the top just look at me
anyone else find this scene really hot
when this alien farts at charger the
alien just looked so feminine and sexy
and the way it farts and turns to him to
flaunt it like it's inviting him to get
closer for the next one I first watched
a movie when I was very young and I have
no no no no a classic an absolute
legendary comment in the YouTube
hemisphere be right back Peter PAH I
gotta do my chores where did he go
please Samuel Martinez come back I want
to find Samuel I want to meet and make a
video with him that would be amazing
I want to know what took him so damn
long I'm back well finally this comment
deserves to be framed it's so it's
fantastic an instantaneous classic top
ten things that will happen when Queen
Elizabeth dies Big Ben just effing
explodes we don't know that for sure
come on I love I love this because it
really encapsulates how over the top
that the thumbnails are and if you
really process them and really think
okay well what are they trying to convey
here most of the time you just look like
an idiot not me though my all my
thumbnails are perfect and flawless
thank you for complimenting me on that
five fortnight youtubers who have sworn
oh my god no this is too far this is why
we have the apocalypse happening
everyone is blaming me for the ad
pocalypse
do you hear me swear do you hear me say
food ali-a I am disappointed in you I
thought you were better than that Wow
haven't we learned a lot here today
YouTube is truly an amazing website for
you full of one nurse and I don't know
standby anyone think it's just uncle cuz
that's not true at all leave a like if
you're proud of being part of the
YouTube community as well I have to
check out some of my other videos
similar to this one also big thanks to
YouTube [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
YT I don't swear I'm not like those
fortnight youtubers but I'll let you
guess where it came from
it's a great Twitter that post similar
memes like this one and as always
brofist everyone